[Music]
so when we see sickness War famine
broken and families drought plagues all
of those are expressions of a Dying
[Music]
World our subject for this evening
questions questions questions what did I
say questions questions questions let's
pray Father in Heaven bless us with an
understanding of your word speak through
me father simply and directly I humble
myself before you I truly do seeking
only your glory and the blessing of your
people use me as an instrument of
blessing touch every listening heart I
pray those seated and those passing by
in Jesus name we pray let all God's
people say amen and amen what I plan to
do today is to preach a sermon that
answers some direct
questions that's why the subject is
questions questions questions question
number one why do we need the Old
Testament if we believe in Jesus who is
the god of the New
Testament why do we need the Old
Testament if we have Jesus who is the
god of the New Testament let me say
immediately that Jesus is the god of the
Bible amen not just the Old Testament
but let me take you to the word of God
very direct irly and show you that the
Old Testament is as essential as the New
Testament and to ignore the Old
Testament is to ignore Christ let us go
to 1 Corinthians chapter 10 we shall
read from verse one our subject is
questions questions
questions and do not hesitate to shout
out slowly please because you know what
my habit is to go to fast I got an email
today they said please Pastor can you
speak slowly I have a friend whose first
language is not English and I have
always to keep that in mind because I
keep forgetting because you speak it so
well 1 Corinthians 10 reading from verse
one moreover Brethren I would not that
ye should be ignorant how all our
fathers were under the cloud and all
passed through the sea and were all
baptized unto Moses in the cloud and in
the sea and they all eat the same
spiritual meat now verse four is
critical and they'd all drink the same
spiritual drink for they drank of that
spiritual rock that followed them finish
the
verse and that rock go on loudly was
Christ now the Bible is very clear the
Rock from which the Israelites drank
represented Christ the divine presence
that followed the Israelites
all through their Wilderness wanderings
was Christ the Bible says for they drank
of that spiritual rock that followed
them and that rock was Christ if you
throw out the Old Testament you throw
out Christ let's keep reading verse 5
but with many of them God was not well
pleased for they were overthrown in the
wilderness now these are our examples to
the intent
we should not lust after evil things as
they also lusted who is they the
Israelites in the wilderness in other
words what happened to them we must
study because their experiences are
examples for us that we should avoid
what they did there is a saying
experience is the best teacher but let
it be someone else's experience not
yours don't get get drunk to know what
drunkenness is like don't take drugs to
know what adduction is like don't commit
crime to know what it is like learn from
other people's
experience so these things were our
examples to the intent verse six we
should not lust after evil things as
they also lusted now here com four
examples of things they lusted after
mistakes they make that we should avoid
neither be idolators as were some of
them
as it is written the people sat down to
eat and drink and Rose up to play and
that's found in Exodus 32 between verse
5 and 6 neither let us commit
fornication as some of them committed
and fell in one day three and 20,000 now
verse 9 neither let us tempt
Christ as some of them also tempted and
were destroyed of serpents the Bible
says when the the Israelites gave God a
hard time in the Old Testament the
person they were irritating was Christ
now listen to the verse again verse 9 1
Corinthians 10 am I going too
quickly all right I'm close to it let me
back
off neither let us tempt Christ the word
tempt means to really try the patience
of God to push God to the Limit as some
of them also tempted and were destroyed
of serpents when did this happen keep
your finger on 1 Corinthians
10:9 let us go to numbers 21 we shall
read verses 5 and 6 we want to identify
the incident when they were destroyed by
serpents because they tempted whom
Christ numbers 21 reading from verse 5
and the people spake against God and
against
Moses let me pause be very careful how
you criticize your
leaders someone gen duly elected by the
church is in that position by the will
of God when you attack that person when
you attack that office you attack
God I'm not saying you must agree with
everything people do I am saying when
you try to undermine leadership of the
church when you constantly attack
leadership of the church when you damage
a person's influence by what you say to
the members you are attacking god listen
to verse 5 numbers 21 and the people
spake against God and against Moses
because Moses was elected by God the
church is the body of Christ when
officers are elected they must be
respected even though we
disagree and the people spake against
God and against Moses say wherefore have
he brought us up out of Egypt to die in
the wilderness for there's no bread and
there's no water and our soul loveth
this light bread the light bread being
the Mana verse 6 read verse 6 with me
and whom the Lord sent what fiery
serpents among the people and they bit
the people and much people of Israel
died now the Bible says the Lord sent
the serpents but the New Testament tells
us who the Lord was and who was that
tell me Jesus Christ now we go back to 1
Corinthians chap
10:9 neither let us tempt Christ as some
of them also tempted and were destroyed
of serpents so we have two verses 1
Corinthians 10:4 the rock that followed
them was Christ 1 Corinthians 10:9 the
god they irritated was Christ let us go
to Hebrews chap 11 we shall read verse
24 and
25 or 24-
26 Hebrews 11 24- 26 our subject is
questions questions questions we're
answering the questions why do we need
the Old Testament when Christ is the god
of the New Testament and I responded
immediately by saying Christ is the god
of the Bible not just the Old Testament
because 2 Timothy 3:16 Says all
scripture is given by inspiration of God
and it's profited
for Doctrine for reproof for correction
for instruction in righteousness how
much scripture all scripture is given by
inspiration all scripture is profitable
now we're in Hebrews
11:24 the Bible says by faith Moses when
he was come to years refused to be
called the son of Pharaoh's daughter
choosing rather to suffer Affliction
with the people of God that they enjoy
the pleasures of sin for the SE
verse the next verse esteeming the
reproach of whom Christ greater riches
than the treasures in Egypt for he had
respect unto the recompense of the
reward when Moses chose the sight of
God's people Moses decided I will accept
any reproach for the name of
Christ esteeming the reproach of
Christ Moses was aware that that power
that spoke to him in the burning bush
that declared the law on SI that was the
rock that followed them the water that
came from the rock the pillar of Fire by
night to keep them warm the pillar of
cloud by dare to keep them cool from the
burning Sun in the desert that was
Christ amen discard the Old Testament
and you discard Jesus Christ let's go
again to 1 Peter chapter 1 1 Peter 1 we
shall read from verse
9 1 Peter chapter 1 1 reading verse 9 I
was told also by a distinguished leader
of the church I don't give you enough
time to find the verses so I Repent in
sackcloth and Ashes and I ask you now
have you found 1 Peter chap 1 reading
from verse
9 receiving the end of your faith even
the salvation of your souls of which
salvation the prophets have inquired in
search diligently who prophesied of the
grace that should come unto you
searching what verse 11 and what manner
of time now Peter is saying the Old
Testament prophets wrote about salvation
that Christ was to bring in person
notice I said bring in person salvation
functioned from the time Adam sinned but
Christ came in person and so verse 11
searching what or what manner of time
the spirit of Christ which was in them
did signify when it testified beforehand
the suffering of Christ and the glory
that should be revealed the Bible is is
clear the spirit that inspired the Old
Testament was whose Spirit the spirit of
Christ now explain to me how do you get
rid of the Old
Testament you're getting rid of
Christ First Corinthians 10:4 the rck
that followed them was Christ 1
Corinthians 109 the god they made Angry
was Christ Hebrews 11: 2526
Moses accepted the reproach of Christ 1
Peter 1:1 the spirit that inspired
Isaiah Jeremiah All Those Old Testament
prophets was the spirit of Christ my
brothers and sisters if you get rid of
the Old Testament you are getting rid of
Christ listen again to our scripture
reading 2 Timothy 3: 16 all scripture
what does that
include the Old Testament all the new
all
scripture is given by
whom inspiration of
God to dump the Old Testament is to dump
a gift from
God all scripture is given by
inspiration of God and is profitable for
Doctrine one of the reasons why people
don't accept doctrines as should they do
not go to the Old
Testament any Doctrine in the new has
its roots in the old yes let me say that
again there is no Doctrine in the New
Testament that has its root in the New
Testament whether salvation forgiveness
repentance the second coming of Christ
state of the Dead the Sabbath the law is
Judgment you choose the doctrine its
root is in the Old
Testament so all scripture is given by
inspiration of God and is profitable for
Doctrine for reproof for
correction and for
instruction in righteousness that the
man of God may be what perfect thly
furnished unto all good works all that
he needs to live a life of good works in
the eyes of God is found in the old and
in the new when you discard the old you
have discarded some of what the man of
God
needs if you thrown it away get it back
listen to John
5:39 I'll let you find it our subject
question questions
questions the first question we're
dealing with why do we need the Old
Testament when Christ is the god of the
new God Christ the Holy Spirit they are
God of the Bible do you have John
5:39 search the scriptures now when
Jesus said that what scripture was he
referring to because the new had not yet
been
written he said search the scriptures
for in them you think he have eternal
life and they are they which testify of
me so Jesus says you want to learn about
me go to the scriptures and all the
scriptures he had had was the Old
Testament when you get rid of the Old
Testament you get rid of a source of
knowledge that Jesus
recommends if that's clear somebody say
amen amen search the scriptures for in
them he think he have eternal life and
they are they which testify of
me my brothers and
sisters the Bible is the old and the new
the same way people were saved in the
New Testament they were saved in the Old
Testament there's only one way to be
saved and that is by faith in Jesus
Christ so you read Hebrews 11: 7 by
faith Noah being warned of God of things
not seen as yet moved with fear prepared
an ark to the saving of his house by
which he condemned the world and became
the heir of the righteousness which is
by faith Noah was saved by Faith amen by
faith Abraham verse 17 when he was tried
offered up Isaac Abraham was saved by
faith even earlier verse four by faith
Abel offered unto God a more excellent
sacrifice than Cain by faith Abel was
accepted verse five by faith Enoch was
translated that he should not see death
and was not found because God had
translated him by faith Enoch was saved
by by faith in the old by faith in the
new the only difference was Christ had
not yet come in the old in person he
came in the new in person but every lamb
sacrifice in the Old Testament was a
symbol of the Lamb that was to come is
that
clear please get back to the Old
Testament if you have thrown it
away question number
two why do I have to keep the law
if I am under what
Grace oh by the way before I get into
that well let me get into it there is
only one reason why people try to throw
away the Old Testament
one
one and it's because of one
chapter can you guess what that chapter
is what chapter is that Exodus chap 20
which contain what the Ten Commandments
that's why people throw away the entire
Old Testament they are trying to get rid
of the
law now let's be more specific people
say we do not have to keep the law we're
under grace they are trying to get rid
of the
Sabbath because the people who say I am
under grace I don't have to keep the law
they want you to obey the Lord that says
Thou shalt not
kill tell me if I'm right they have they
want you to obey the Lord that says Thou
shalt not take my wife commit adultery
what they are really targeting is the
Sabbath
commandment but to get rid of it they
say we don't need the law to get rid of
the Ten Commandments as a whole they say
we don't need the Old Testament you keep
that up you'll eventually come to the
place where you say we don't need what
the entire
Bible if you live long enough and you
step on that path I don't need the Old
Testament I don't need the law you come
to the place inevitably where you
conclude I don't need the
Bible but God in his Mercy Cuts people
off before they reach a point of no
return in the rejection of Truth why do
I have to keep the law if I am under
grace go to Romans chapter 6 we'll read
verses 14 and 15 of Romans chapter
6 you're not telling me to slow
down you
should so if I rush off like a
train and someone doesn't understand I
will point the person to
you to
explain it'll be your fault not mine
what book did I say what chapter what
verse
14 for sin shall not not have dominion
over you for ye what not under the but
under now Paul says that in one verse
which a lot of Christians love to read
ah you see we are not under the law
we're under grace but they do not read
the very next verse read it out loud
with me What then shall we because we're
not under the but under finish the verse
God forbid
now what is
sin now okay read verse 15 again using
that uh definition read nice and Loud
come on What then shall we no no no no
no what is
sin Now read verse 15 using that What
then shall we transgress the law go on
because we're under grace and not under
the law God forbid
what does God forbid
[Music]
mean are you with me God
forbid that your position under grace
gives you the right to break the
law go to Romans
3:31 I believe it's Romans
3:31 if it's not Romans 3:31 is it's
Romans
3:31 what does that verse eight do we
then do what make void the law through
faith yeah we do what establish the law
now Faith must be used twice even though
it's mentioned once do we then make vo
the law through faith God forbid yeah we
establish the law through faith even
though that's not written that's what
the writer means faith in God is the
means by which we establish his law my
brothers and sisters any man under Grace
Finds the law as an expression of love
for his savior being under the law means
under the
condemnation of the
law when I see a policeman I am
pleased you know why he represents
order he represents uh protection from
harm and hurt when a criminal sees a
policeman he tries to hide why because
he is under the condemnation of the law
that's why the Bible says the law was
not made for a righteous man in other
words it was not emphasized written on
stone for the righteous man because the
righteous man is the law abiding
man are you with me no if you drive
through a
neighborhood nice neighborhood nice
clean Lawns nice walls nice houses very
very clean and neat you don't put up a
sign please don't throw garbage on the
ground because there's none oh yes now
you go through a neighborhood with
garbage all over the place what do you
do you put up a sign please pick up your
garbage are you with me so that there's
no long need did for the neat clean
neighborhood because they do it
naturally amen but for the neighborhood
where people throw things all over the
place there must be a law pick it
up for the person who truly loves Christ
in whose heart Christ dwells no law
needs to be written the law comes out of
the heart and so the Bible says the law
is not written for a righteous man it is
written for a sinner the word written
means
emphasized in connection with I am under
grace not under law therefore I break
the law go to Jeremiah 31 let's read
verse 33 because in connection with that
is the claim some Christians make I am a
new Covenant
Christian I don't have to keep the law I
am a New Covenant Christian let's look
at the New Covenant as prophesied by
Jeremiah Jeremiah 131 reading verse 33
but this shall be the Covenant that I
will make you the house of Israel after
those day say the Lord I will put my law
where in their inward parts and write it
where in their hearts and will be their
God and they shall be my people that's a
prophetic statement of something that
would be done now let's go to Hebrews
chapter
10 here is Paul talking about the
Fulfillment of of Jeremiah
31:33 Hebrews
10:16 when you have it say Amen so I
know I've given you time to find
it all
right do we all have Hebrews 10:16 for
this oh someone said no look in the New
Testament whoever it was that said no
somewhere towards the back of the Bible
somebody helped that nice person find
Hebrews but since we haven't got all
night we have to press on can you say
amen amen Hebrews 10:16 what does the
Bible say for this shall be the Covenant
that I will make with them after those
days save the Lord I will do what put my
law in the and right and in their hearts
will I write them I will put my laws in
their hearts in their mind and in their
hearts will I write them
now what
law does God write in the heart under
the New Testament the same law he wrote
where on
Stone in the old is simply transferred
from Stone and put where on the
heart the New Covenant does not present
a different set of
laws it is just a different location for
the right wrting of the law symbolically
under the Old Testament the law was
written on tables of stone and kept in
the ark through Christ it is written on
the
heart which by the way was the way
Abraham
lived let me say I hope it doesn't
confuse you everyone who's ever been
saved has been saved by the New
Covenant Abraham was saved by the New
Covenant the law was in his heart Adam
Noah Enoch New
Covenant the law in the heart because of
slavery in Egypt they had forgotten God
that's why Moses said give me a name
that I may tell them so God had to take
a kindergarten approach a primary school
approach with visual aids the law on
tables of stone the sanctuary visual age
for these kindergarten people but Noah
Abraham Seth all those holy men the law
was on the heart Jesus came to
reestablish that under the Old Testament
the law was on tables of stone under the
New Testament the same law is written on
the heart it is not done away with it is
not changed my brothers and sisters the
same law but it is written on the heart
so if you are a new testament Christian
the law the Old Testament Christians
were supposed to keep you and and I are
required if we love Jesus Christ to keep
third
question I was
christened why do I have to be
baptized well let me say I was
christened
too cuz I grew up as a
Catholic I was properly christened by a
priest pour some water on my
forehead I didn't know what was going on
I was told years later the priest did
not realize that a prerequisite for
baptism is
repentance H you didn't understand what
I just said let me say it again when
Peter preached on the day of Pentecost
and in verse 37 of Acts chapter 2 the
Bible says when they heard this they
were picked in their hearts and said
unto Peter and the rest of the Apostles
men and Brethren what shall we do then
Peter said unto them repent and be
baptise every one of you in the name of
Jesus Christ for the remission of sins
and he shall receive the gift of the
Holy Ghost no baby has any sins to
confess no baby can repent repentance
requires an knowledge of wrongdoing a
six-month-old baby in the arms of a
priest cannot be
baptized his head can be wet but he
cannot be baptized why let us look at
what baptism is physically and what it
represents spiritually Matthew chapter 3
reading from verse 13 Matthew 3 reading
from verse
13 gospel number one before Matthew met
Jesus Christ like zakus he was a
thief but when you meet Christ you go
from Thief to gospel writer can you say
Amen Paul was a murderer when he
collided with Christ Christ straightened
his thinking he went from being a
murderer to a soul winner can you say
amen amen Mary Magdalene was a
prostitute she became the first person
to see the Risen Christ Christ can
change your life drastically if that's
what you want let me say it again Christ
has the power to change your life
drastically if that's what you want and
that change includes changing bad habits
you've cultivated and changing bad
habits you've
inherited now inherited means it's
genetic and something genetic is
supposed to be scientifically
unchangeable but the blood of Jesus
Christ can change genetics amen you've
inherited something from your father or
from your
mother the power of Christ can change
it Matthew 3 reading from verse 13 then
cometh Jesus From Galilee to Jordan unto
John to be baptized of him but John
forbad him saying I have need to be
baptized of thee and comest thou to me
and you can understand why John said
that he recognized Jesus as the Savior
how can a sinner baptize a sinless man
Jesus answered and said unto him suffer
it to be so now verse 15 for thus it
becometh us to fulfill all
righteousness which immediately means
baptism is an act of
what slow let's go back to verse 15
suffer it to be so now Jesus say do it
for thus it becometh us to fulfill all
righteousness baptism is an act of what
righteousness so he suffered him verse
16 and Jesus when he was baptized went
up straight away out of the water now
use your imagination to come up out of
water where would you have to be first
in the water which tells us immediately
that baptism requires a lot of water the
Bible says and Jesus Jesus when he was
baptized went up straight away out of
the water and lo the heavens were open
unto him and he saw the spirit of God
descending like a dove and lighting upon
him and L verse 17 a voice from Heaven
saying this is my beloved Son in whom I
am well please now think with me Jesus
is called the second
one the second
Adam why are we possessed with a sinful
nature
because the first Adam sinned and
contaminated the whole race now Jesus is
the second Adam when God said to Jesus
this is my beloved Son in whom I am well
pleased that statement of acceptance by
the father extends to everyone who in
obedience to Christ decides to be
baptized because Christ represented you
in the act of baptism and represented me
as the second Adam let me say it again
when God the father said this is my
beloved Son in whom I am well pleased
that statement of acceptance extends to
everyone who in obedience to Christ
decides to be baptized so those of you
who will be baptized this weekend and
the next when you come up out of the
water by faith you must hear the father
say what this is my beloved Son or this
is my beloved daughter finish it for me
in whom I am well pleased come on
somebody say amen amen baptism pleases
God but it requires a lot of
water why does it require so much
water let's go to Romans 6 reading from
verse one Romans 6 reading from verse 1
let me slow down no one is helping
me Romans 6 reading from verse
one do you have
Romans do you have Romans okay what
shall we say then shall we continue in
sin that Grace May abound God forbid how
shall we that are dead to sin live any
longer therein know ye not now listen
carefully to verse four of verse three
that so many of us as we're baptized
into Christ finish the verse we're
baptized into his death through the
right of baptism we by faith enter into
the death burial and Resurrection
experience of Jesus Christ know ye not
that so many of us as we're baptized
into Christ we baptized into his death
verse four therefore we are bed with
Christ by baptism into death that like
as Christ was raised up from the dead by
the glory of the father
even so we also should walk in newness
of Life what Paul is saying we must
participate spiritually in the death the
burial and the resurrection of Jesus
Christ listen to verse five for if we
have been planted together in the
likeness of his word we shall also be in
the likeness of his resurrection planted
means
buried here is why water is required
when you decide to be baptized you have
made a decision to give up your own life
of sin and living in error you have
decided I have learned truth I choose
the truth I give up my life of error and
sin and I want to live a new life now
you have died to your own life by that
decision now the preacher takes you and
he puts you down what is that that's the
burial as Christ was put down then after
one second the preacher brings you up
what is that the resurrection now can
you do that with
christening you must be buried to
fulfill the
symbol now the water of baptism is not
what saves you you've already accepted
Christ but it is an act of obedience to
the one who saved
you you must go
down come
up no KN this verse 6 that our old man
is crucified with him that the body of
sin might be destroyed that henceforth
we should not serve sin not from
henceforth you won't make a mistake you
won't serve sin so the baptized person
now has a new Lord whom he or she serves
and that Lord is Christ baptism requires
a lot of water the very word baptism
comes from the Greek word baptism which
means to immerse or to dip and it was a
c the word was borrowed from uh trades
people who dyed
cloth you take a white piece of cloth
back in those days to dye it you dipped
it entirely under the dye red blue and
the white cloth came up a different
color the church then took that word
baptizo to represent the symbol of going
under coming up a different person so
verse 5 says even so we should rise to
walk in newness of life you go down one
person symbolically notice I say
symbolically you come up a different
person this is based on the fact that
Jesus when he died was different from
the Jesus Who
Rose let me explain before Jesus died
and Rose there were some things he could
not
do Jesus could not just appear in a room
and disappear he couldn't do that after
he rose with his glorified body he can
appear and disappear right through a
solid door by the way the Bible says
that's the body we will have when we
make it to Heaven Can you say Amen
Philippians
3:20 Jesus rose with a glorified body no
longer to suffer hunger and all the
weaknesses of the flesh which is the
body with which we will rise when this
Mortal puts on immortality when this
corruptible puts on incorruption and so
when you go down in your mind you you
symbolically come up different new
powers and that new power is the power
of the Life of Christ in you why should
I be baptized if I was Christen because
christening is not baptism and I speak
with great respect for anyone listening
to me who may have been Christian listen
to me when you follow Christ you do
things Christ's way the biblical way the
entire nation of Israel was baptized
under the cloud and in the sea 1
Corinthians 10 verse one all baptized as
that Nation came out of the land of
Egypt which is sin into the land of the
Wilderness God had prepared for them
when you leave the land of sin you pass
through the waters of baptism to be
cleansed and you move on up walking
handin hand with God as your pillar of
cloud by day your Pillar of Fire by
night your source of water from a rock
your food from above in other words
living by faith in
God
[Music]
let me review and make a
call why do I have to keep the the why
do I need the Old Testament when Christ
is the god of the new Christ is the god
of what the whole Bible how much
scripture is given by inspiration all
how much is profitable for Doctrine for
Repro for correction for instruction in
righteousness
all you need the Old Testament who was
it that provided food from heaven for
the Israelites in the wilderness Christ
who was it that provided water from a
rod whom did they tempt that sent
serpents to bite them Christ What Spirit
led the the Old Testament prophets to
write the Books they wrote The Spirit of
Christ whom did Moses understand was
with him when he chose to be with the
Israelites
Christ get rid of the Old Testament you
get rid of Christ let me say again the
reason why people try to get rid of the
Old Testament is to get rid of Exodus 20
which contains what the law when they
can't get rid of the Old Testament they
try to get rid of the law in order to
get rid of what the Sabbath
yes question two why do I have to keep
the law if I'm under grace because the
very verse 14 of Romans 6:14 Romans 6:14
says for sin shall not have dominion
over you for you not under the law but
under grace the very next verse says
What then shall we sin or transgress the
law because we're under grace God forbid
God forbids anyone under grace to
transgress his law simple as that let me
say it again God
forbids anyone under grace to transgress
his law question number three if I have
been christened do I need to be baptized
the answer is yes because christening is
not baptism baptism is the symbolic
entering into the death the resurrection
burial and the resurrection of Jesus
Christ that death is death to your life
that burial when you go under the water
that's Resurrection when the preacher
brings you up and I keep saying
symbolically because the moment you
accept Christ the change has already
occurred but Christ wants a public
expression of that private change are
you with me someone seeing you baptized
may decide to be baptized you don't live
your Christian Life just for you A
friend of mine sent me a WhatsApp
message 3 days ago said I don't feel
like going to church today this sabbath
I wrote back and said well I understand
but you just can't think of you your
absence may damage someone's spiritual
experience you go because by someone
just seeing you in church might be
encouraged don't just go to church for
you or don't just stay home for you
remember your presence may be a blessing
to someone else think of others not just
yourself so when you're baptized and
people
see someone may say that guy got
baptized if he can get baptized I can
get
baptized that's the way people think
many people commit crimes because they
see other people commit
crimes we are
copycats well let's copy righteousness
can you say amen amen
tonight I preach three little
sermons to clarify critical
issues I'm going to makeing a call right
now three
calls
one those of you who say based on what I
heard tonight I realize that the Old
Testament is as inspired as the new and
I need both if that is your commitment
may I see your right hand I need both
old and new raise your hand hands down
God bless you God has recorded your
response two being under grace does not
give me the right to commit
murder which is different way of saying
being under grace does not give me the
right to disregard God's law let me say
it again being under grace does not give
me the right to steal or commit murder
or steal somebody's spouse how many of
you will say father I am under grace but
I'm still required by Christ to keep his
law can I see your right hand and by his
grace I'll keep his law hands
down those of you who understand that
baptism is entering symbolically into
the death burial and resurrection of
Jesus Christ and that christening does
not do that if you understand that let
me see your right
hand christening cannot do it because
you don't go under hands down now a
specific
call this coming Sabbath we're having a
baptism we'll have one on the 3 first as
well I'm calling all those who've made
decisions to be baptized this coming
Sabbath or the
next I want you to come let's pray
Before I Let You Go come from where you
are come you made a decision to be
baptized
come come quickly I know you take your
time I'll wait the sooner you come the
sooner I let you go you've made that
decision
come don't wait to see who's coming
first be
first God bless you come you've made
that decision
come let's pray some decisions are
always to be repeated you ask wives they
always want the husbands to say I love
you that's a repetition every day don't
let her assume say it
come let Heaven and Earth see you have
kept your word as God keeps his I will
be baptized that's my decision
come
if you already have your names that's
fine come who will make the decision for
the first time tonight I want to be
baptized whether this sabbath the next
Sabbath or some other time who will make
the decision I want to be baptized in
obedience to Christ you're doing so for
the first time tonight come first time
come if you're afraid ask your friend to
walk with you I am deciding tonight I
want to be
baptized make the decision the date can
be set some other time just make the
decision come I want to be baptized
[Music]
come and some who made the decision are
not here tonight we understand that come
my brother come God bless you I am
deciding tonight I want to be
baptized
[Music]
come
and while you're thinking of coming
those of you seated how many of you will
say father thank you for your word thank
you for the explanation I recommit my
life to you how many of you will say
that can I see your right hand thank you
for the explanations thank you for the
word I recommit the life please stand
with us please stand with
us God bless God bless you the latest
call is I deciding tonight to be
baptized
come make the decision
that's the biggest step make the
decision someone else
[Music]
come somebody else 10 after 7:00 I want
to let you go by
7:15 someone else come a decision to be
baptized God bless my good brother who
just came God bless you someone else
come decision to be baptized it does not
have to be this weekend or the next but
it is essential that you show God where
your heart is on the side of Truth and
obedience make the decision I want to be
baptized
come always come in the direction of
Bible truth come my brother come my
sister please come I call as your
brother not just a preacher your
brother God bless you God bless
you give that life to Christ who paid
for it with his blood somebody else come
I am making a decision to be baptized to
obey God's
law to live in accordance with truth and
not
tradition with Bible fact and not
feeling somebody else come 60 seconds I
pray in the presence of a holy God I
choose to follow the example of Jesus
Christ and be baptized that by faith I
may hear hear God say that is my beloved
Son that is my beloved daughter in whom
I am well
pleased 45
[Music]
seconds somebody else I know someone
else needs to come I wish you would
come 30
seconds a decision to be
baptized
the devil has too many people on his
side let's come on the side of Christ
which is the side of Truth 15
seconds I deciding tonight to be
baptized doesn't have to be this a
weekend or the next make the decision as
the spirit speaks to you make it before
the conviction leaves you and if it
leaves you it does not come back 60
seconds are up I'm going to start
praying those of you who've come if we
do not yet have your names give it to us
if we already have your names that's
fine we don't want to give your
necessary work heads bowed eyes closed
loving father in Heaven we thank you for
your word de God we thank you that all
scripture old and new is given by
inspiration of God and is profitable for
Doctrine for reproof for correction for
instruction and righteousness that the
man of God or the woman of of God may be
perfect thly furnished in other words
having everything that person needs to
live an upright life unto all good works
we thank you de God that being under
grace does not give us the right to
commit murder or to steal or to lie it
is by the power of your grace that we
obey your law we thank you de God that
your word is clear baptism requires
going under the water so christening
does not qualify baptism requires
repentance of sin no baby can do that so
we thank you for enlightening truth dear
God and for those who've come to say we
want to obey Jesus and be baptized and
father as in previous nights I pause one
more time 30 seconds somebody else come
finally lay down your fight with God and
say I am making a decision tonight to be
baptized I am doing what is right come
come come
please I'm not calling you to commit a
sin to commit crime I'm calling you to
do what's right 20 seconds somebody else
a decision to be baptized just make the
decision there's power in a decision 10
seconds somebody else come you know who
you are you ought to come to say to God
I am deciding publicly to be baptized
baptized Father in Heaven move upon
hearts that as I pray the persons may
come thank you de God for the clarity of
your word if it is read honestly thank
you Father even for the struggles that
some people are having right now because
it means they are thinking and so I pray
that you would help them with their
thinking they God and take them by the
hand by the arm put your arms around
them with the spirit and bring them de
God to the point of d Vision to be
baptized into the death the burial and
the resurrection of Jesus Christ that
they may rise symbolically they God to
live a new life a double blessing upon
those who came father keep them firm in
the decision that no power on Earth will
change their minds because we know no
power in heaven will try to change it
because their decision is Right bless
every man every woman every boy every
girl thank you for your word thank you
for your spirit bless us I pray take
take us home safely bring us back
tomorrow to hear your word again I offer
this prayer in Jesus name let all God's
people say amen
am